[Music]
there are four fundamental forces of
nature as we now understand it there's
gravity and electromagnetism which are
the classic forces which were known
already in prehistory and and known in
some form to the ancient Greeks but
which had mature theories in the case of
gravity already in the 17th century with
Newton and in the 19th century with
Maxwell and very beautiful descriptions
and in case of gravity made even more
beautiful with Einstein's general theory
of relativity in the early 20th century
but in the course of studying subatomic
physics and in what goes on at very very
short distances people found they needed
two additional forces that gravity and
electromagnetism aren't enough and the
two additional forces are called the
strong and weak forces what I got the
Nobel Prize for was figuring out the
equations of the strong force and
equally important not just guessing the
equations but showing how you could test
them and see that they were right this
was something I did as a graduate
student I was of course working very
closely with my thesis advisor very very
gifted and powerful physicist named
David gross what so how did we go about
doing it well there were some there were
the experimental situation regarding the
strong interaction was very confused
desperately confused there was no theory
even remotely worthy of standing behind
beside Newton's theory of gravity or
Einsteins or Maxwell's theory of
electromagnetism there were just a lot
of rules of thumb and a lot of confusing
data what we did was focus on one
particular phenomena and tried to
understand just that putting off all
other aspects of this confusing
situation the phenomena we tried to
understand seemed so paradoxical so
crazy that we thought if we could
understand that we could understand
anything basically and and also see
because it seemed so profound and
fundamental actually David thought that
we could prove that it couldn't that you
couldn't understand that within the
standard framework of quantum mechanics
and relativity and that would be a very
important result too because we tell
physicists they had to go back to the
drawing board
this aspect that we were trying to
explain was the fact that quarks which
were somewhat speculative but a pretty
clear indication of reality at that time
when they get close together
hardly interact at all or when they're
moving at very high velocity relative to
one another at high energy again they
don't interact very much at all but if
you try to pull them apart a significant
distance which means in this case ten to
the minus thirteen centimeters or more
[Music]
or if they're moving slowly then they
have very very powerful forces in fact
you can't extract single quarks from
matter they always exist bound to one
another inside protons and neutrons so
we needed a force which gets weaker at
short distances and grows as the
distance growth that's a very
paradoxical
and difficult thing to imagine and make
consistent with the other laws of
physics that we know now there were
powerful mathematical techniques for
investigating that kind of question that
had been developed in other for other
purposes called renormalization group so
we were able to bring those techniques
to bear and address this question and
there were very difficult calculations
it wasn't entirely clear that they were
consistent that you could actually do
this kind of calculation in the kind of
theory that
that was most beautiful that we wanted
to investigate but we insisted on hoping
that the most beautiful equations would
be the right equations and we found out
that a very very special class of
theoretical constructions with
tremendous amounts of symmetry could
give you this behavior so that was that
was I like to say that I compare that to
[Music]
Archimedes saying that if you give me a
lever and a place to stand I can lift
the world based on that kind of leverage
given by the sort of basic principles
and faith and symmetry and beauty plus
this one fact about the forces getting
weaker we were led to quite a unique
proposal for what the equations of the
strong interaction should be and we
could develop some consequences of those
equations and then propose to
experimenters that they go out and check
whether these consequences are correct
now it took several years afterwards
before it became clear that those
consequences we predicted were correct
but they are and in subsequent years
that's become more and more clear the
theory has been used for a wide variety
of applications now with great success
and the kind of thing that in the early
days was called testing quantum
chromodynamics or testing asymptotic
freedom is now called calculating
backgrounds so it's gone from being a
glamorous exploration of new worlds to
kind of taking care of the garbage that
you could you can look for more
interesting things but it's well
although it sounds in a way it's kind of
a step down you know if you if I you
know look at it in the big picture its
glorious that you have a theory that was
originally very speculative and just
something that existed in our minds
and we had and it's gone now to being
and absolutely accepted and basic part
of our understanding of nature and a
very beautiful
[Music]